le groom et la houppette les plus
célèbres de la bande dessinée réunis
depuis ce week end la bibliothèque de
versailles accueille dans la galerie des
affaires étrangères une exposition
consacrée à tintin et à spirou ce
dernier souffle ses 75 bougies tandis
que le journal de tintin fête ses 65 ans
les deux personnages ont popularisé la
bd en france et en belgique dans les
librairies
il n'attire pas les mêmes lecteurs alors
c'est pas les mêmes ventes et c'est pas
le même public
tintin c'est une vente classique c'est
beaucoup les grands parents qui veulent
faire découvrir sa à leurs petits
enfants
parce que maintenant les collectionneurs
de tintin ils ont toute la série donc
y'a plus spirou ils sont restés dans
l'actualité et ils sortent toujours des
nouveautés après ça plaît ou ça plaît
pas mais en tout cas il se met vraiment
à la conquête d'un nouveau public
s'il présente des caractéristiques
communes belges reporter un acolyte un
animal de compagnie
tintin semble avoir une longueur
d'avancé sur spirou qu'en termes de
popularité
je préfère tintin parce que c'est un
type ordinaire ça l'ouest comme vous et
et des jouets mais des joueurs je trouve
des histoires un peu plus grand niveau
tata c'est aussi et le monde journalisme
et curiosité la jeunesse et du capitaine
haddock et tous ses bons mots sont
restés à il suffit d'un coup d'un recul
d'entendre le regard jour du nos petits
enfants
bachi bouzouk et cetera y connaissent
encore l'exposition tintin spirou match
retour se déroule jusqu'au 13 juillet